La méthode de diagonalisation quantique basée sur l'échantillonnage, ou SQD en abrégé, est un algorithme hybride quantique-classique comme la
diagonalisation quantique de Krylov KQD, comme VQE et bien d'autres. En utilisant de tels algorithmes hybrides,
il peut être utile de réfléchir à l'endroit où chaque algorithme tire parti du calcul quantique et classique. Rappelle-toi que VQE crée des états sur un
circuit en utilisant des paramètres optimisés classiquement. Dans ce cas, l'état lui-même est sur un ordinateur quantique. Bien que
l'obtention de l'état cible soit un processus qui combine à la fois le calcul classique et quantique.
La valeur d'espérance de l'opérateur est calculée à l'aide de mesures quantiques.
Mais une combinaison classique de termes est également nécessaire.
En revanche, SQD utilise un ordinateur quantique pour générer un sous-espace utile sur lequel le Hamiltonien ou un autre opérateur peut être
projeté. Le Hamiltonien est ensuite diagonalisé entièrement classiquement pour trouver l'état cible. Supposons qu'on ait un
problème d'intérêt scientifique ou industriel qui peut être formulé comme un problème de solveur propre sur une matrice de n lignes et
n colonnes. Supposons en outre que n soit assez grand pour que la diagonalisation classique exacte ne soit pas une option. Il
serait clairement avantageux de réduire les dimensions de notre matrice tout en préservant toutes les caractéristiques pertinentes de l'état fondamental. C'est en effet l'
objectif de nombreuses approches de solveur propre approximatives, y compris les méthodes de Krylov classiques. Supposons qu'on en sache assez sur notre problème pour faire une
supposition raisonnablement bonne sur la forme de l'état fondamental, mais pas assez pour résoudre le problème directement. Dans ce
cas, on pourrait faire de nombreuses mesures de notre approximation correcte de l'état fondamental cible. Les résultats de ces
mesures nous donnent un sous-espace d'états de la base computationnelle qui contient toutes les composantes pertinentes de notre
état fondamental. Projeter sur ce sous-espace donnerait une matrice plus petite qui contient toujours les degrés de liberté pertinents.
Le flux de travail pour ça est le suivant. Tu commences par choisir un bon
ansatz. Plus précisément, choisis un ansatz dont le support coïncide avec celui de l'état cible. On va discuter exactement de ce que
ça signifie. Ensuite, mesure l'état dans la base computationnelle comme c'est fait avec la primitive sampler.
Puis, utilise les résultats de l'échantillonnage pour définir un sous-espace qui contient l'état fondamental.
Ensuite, projette ta matrice sur ce sous-espace. Enfin, diagonalise classiquement la matrice projetée plus petite.
Décortiquons chacune de ces étapes, en accordant une attention particulière à la définition du sous-espace.
Dans tout le domaine de l'informatique quantique, choisir un bon ansatz est toujours critique. Dans le cas de SQD, ton choix d'ansatz
déterminera quels états de la base computationnelle pourront être mesurés lors de l'échantillonnage.
Le vrai état fondamental peut être exprimé comme une superposition d'un sous-ensemble d'états de la base computationnelle. Ce sous-ensemble
est appelé le support de l'état fondamental. Pour obtenir une bonne estimation de ton état fondamental et de son énergie, tes ansatz
doivent avoir une projection non nulle sur les états de la base computationnelle dans le support de l'état fondamental.
Ce diagramme représente l'espace engendré par tous les états possibles sur le nombre de qubits utilisés. On veut un
ansatz dont le support contient le support du vrai état fondamental.
Considérons un exemple de système très petit avec un état fondamental s_ground = 8 fois
l'état 1 0 0 plus 6 fois l'état 001.
Ceci a un support composé de ces deux vecteurs 1 0 0 et 0 1. Disons que l'ansatz est de la forme SNZOT 1 est A fois
l'état 1 0 0 plus B fois l'état 0 1 0 plus C fois l'état 001. De sorte que son
support est l'ensemble des trois vecteurs 1 0 0 1 0 et 0 0 1, un sur-ensemble du
support de l'état fondamental. C'est un bon ansatz.
Imagine maintenant qu'on ait plutôt choisi un ansatz de la forme szots 2 est a fois l'
état 1 1 0 plus b fois l'état 011.
Ceci a un support composé de ces deux vecteurs 11 1 0 et 011 qui n'a aucun chevauchement avec le support de l'état
fondamental. C'est un mauvais ansatz.
Note qu'on n'exige pas nécessairement que l'ansatz soit une bonne approximation de l'état fondamental. L'ansatz pourrait
avoir un support bien plus grand ou les coefficients pourraient être très différents sur l'ansatz et le vrai état fondamental et quand même bien fonctionner.
À ce stade, on a utilisé un ansatz bien motivé pour faire adopter à l'ordinateur quantique un état similaire à notre état cible.
Montré ici est l'ansatz unitaire couplé de type gaz ou UCJ qui est très utile en chimie quantique.
On veut maintenant mesurer l'état du système en obtenant des chaînes de bits décrivant l'état effondré de chaque
qubit. Rappelle-toi que l'estimation du Hamiltonien comme dans VQE nécessite de nombreuses mesures quantiques. C'est en partie pour
réduire l'incertitude et en partie à cause du nombre de groupes de Pauli commutants qui composent le Hamiltonien.
Dans les méthodes d'échantillonnage, tu as toujours besoin de beaucoup de mesures, mais les raisons sont différentes. Maintenant, on a besoin de nombreuses mesures pour effectivement échantillonner les
nombreux états de la base computationnelle impliqués dans les états quantiques fortement intriqués. Dans SQD, les chaînes de bits échantillonnées correspondent
aux configurations du système simulé. Si le système étudié est soumis à des contraintes absolues comme des
lois de conservation en physique ou chimie, alors la plupart des états mesurés seront valides. Mais certaines chaînes de bits échantillonnées
correspondent à des configurations invalides ou non physiques dues au bruit et aux erreurs. Un processus appelé
récupération de configuration vise à affiner ces échantillons bruyants en un ensemble de configurations plus précises.
Ce processus consiste à générer de nouvelles configurations en retournant probabilistement des bits individuels basé sur
les occupations orbitales moyennées et les nombres de particules connus.
Les configurations affinées sont ensuite utilisées pour couvrir des sous-espaces pour la projection et la diagonalisation du Hamiltonien,
améliorant itérativement la fidélité de la représentation de l'état quantique.
Regardons un exemple triviale petit de récupération de configuration pour en comprendre le sens. Suppose qu'on mesure un
système quantique avec quatre qubits représentant quatre orbitales moléculaires et qu'on obtienne les chaînes de bits suivantes du
processeur quantique. Chaque chaîne de bits représente l'occupation d'une orbitale. Un pour
occupée, zéro pour inoccupée. Qiskit utilise une notation dans laquelle le qubit le moins significatif est à l'extrême droite.
Par exemple, 1 0 1 0 indique que les orbitales 1 et trois sont occupées. Ces
mesures ont été choisies pour des raisons pédagogiques uniquement. Les occupations résultantes peuvent ne pas correspondre à un système physique. Dans les contextes physiques, il est
souvent le cas que le système a un nombre total de particules connu. Il peut aussi y avoir d'autres lois de conservation que
tu peux utiliser pour déterminer la physicalité d'un état mesuré. Pour rester concret, supposons que notre système est
connu pour avoir un nombre total de particules de n= 2. Ça nous dit le nombre total de uns qui devraient apparaître dans notre étiquette d'état,
ce qu'on appelle une contrainte de poids de Hamming.
Cependant, certaines configurations mesurées violent cette contrainte. L'état 1 0 1 0 est physiquement valide. Mais l'état 1 1
1 0 a trop de particules et l'état de tous les zéros a trop peu de particules. Zéro
en fait. Ces violations peuvent être dues au bruit dans le système ou à des erreurs de mesure. On a besoin d'un moyen de revenir
à des configurations qui ont un sens physique, du moins de manière approximative.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la récupération de configuration.
Pour corriger nos échantillons bruyants, on retourne probabilistement des bits dans des configurations invalides basé sur l'occupation
orbitale moyenne calculée sur les configurations valides.
Les occupations orbitales sont les valeurs d'espérance de l'opérateur nombre agissant sur chaque orbitale. Ceci est estimé et
affiné de manière auto-cohérente en utilisant les états produits par SQD. Regardons l'orbitale 2 par exemple. Dans deux des
quatre configurations valides, l'orbitale 2 était occupée. Ça nous donne une occupation attendue de 0,5.
On fait la même chose pour les trois autres orbitales. Maintenant on revient à une configuration invalide 1 1 0. On peut retourner un des
bits de 1 à zéro pour générer une configuration valide. Mais lequel doit-on retourner ? Une façon de décider est
par la déviation de l'occupation de chaque orbitale par rapport aux moyennes qu'on vient de calculer.
Ici on voit que la plus grande différence est dans l'occupation de l'orbitale un. Donc on pourrait s'attendre à ce que le bit un soit
retourné de un à zéro. Bien sûr, l'orbitale 2 n'est pas loin derrière. Et il est toujours possible, bien que peu probable, que
cet état mesuré soit le résultat de multiples erreurs sur le même état.
Choisir uniquement la plus grande déviation par rapport à la moyenne pour tous les états invalides n'est pas optimal. À la place, les bits sont retournés
probabilistement avec une probabilité étant une fonction des différences montrées ici. Supposons que dans ce
cas on change bien le bit qui diffère le plus de l'occupation moyenne. Donc 1 1 0 devient 1 1 0 0. On ferait le
même processus pour l'autre choix invalide. Disons que dans ce cas on finit par retourner les bits un et trois.
Après ce processus de correction, on a un nouvel ensemble de configurations qui pourrait ressembler à ça.
En utilisant cet ensemble affiné, on peut mettre à jour l'occupation orbitale moyenne pour améliorer la fidélité. Dans notre cas, les nouvelles
occupations sont celles-ci.
Ce processus de récupération itératif garantit que les mesures bruyantes sont filtrées en configurations physiquement significatives,
améliorant la précision des approximations d'états propres dans SQD. L'add-on Qiskit SQD dispose de quelques outils qui
seront utiles dans ce processus. Si on a bien échantillonné les états dans le support du vrai état fondamental
du système, alors on devrait pouvoir regarder uniquement les parties du Hamiltonien qui agissent sur ce sous-espace
et quand même obtenir un bon état fondamental et une bonne énergie. Dans notre exemple trivial de 4 qubits, il y a initialement 2 ou 16
états possibles du système. En utilisant une combinaison d'échantillonnage et de récupération de configuration, on réduit ça
à trois états dans notre sous-espace d'intérêt. Trois états qu'on espère constituer le support du vrai état fondamental.
On projette maintenant notre Hamiltonien complet sur ce sous-espace. C'est-à-dire qu'on fait une matrice M d'une colonne de vecteurs de notre
sous-espace échantillonné récupéré et une analogue M dagger des lignes et on multiplie M dagger HM
visuellement. Ça signifie prendre les éléments de la matrice dans les lignes et colonnes correspondant aux états dans notre
sous-espace échantillonné récupéré. Les lignes et colonnes mises en évidence sont celles correspondant à notre sous-espace. Et les
boîtes plus sombres mises en évidence là où elles se chevauchent sont les éléments qu'on garde pour notre nouvelle matrice projetée.
Maintenant qu'on a sélectionné le sous-espace d'intérêt, on peut diagonaliser cette matrice sur un ordinateur classique
en utilisant un solveur standard. Si le vrai état fondamental est entièrement composé d'états dans notre sous-espace, cette
diagonalisation devrait donner le bon état fondamental et l'énergie de l'état fondamental. Si on a seulement la plupart du support de l'état fondamental,
on pourrait s'en approcher. Une fois qu'on a obtenu l'état fondamental pour ce Hamiltonien projeté, on a un état très
utile à partir duquel calculer l'occupation moyenne de chaque orbitale.
Précédemment, nos occupations étaient calculées à partir d'états qu'on avait échantillonnés en utilisant un ansatz qu'on espérait aider
à approcher notre état fondamental. Mais il n'y avait aucune garantie que l'occupation moyenne de chaque orbitale issue de cet échantillonnage correspondait à l'occupation
dans l'état d'énergie minimale. Revenons en arrière. On avait un échantillonnage d'états computationnels. On a utilisé la récupération de configuration
pour corriger ceux qui étaient physiquement invalides. Ensuite on a calculé l'occupation orbitale moyenne en les utilisant tous. L'
état fondamental pourrait n'en inclure que certains. L'état fondamental de ce Hamiltonien projeté n'est peut-être pas le vrai état fondamental
de notre système original, mais c'est l'état d'énergie minimale qui peut être créé en utilisant n'importe quelle superposition des
états récupérés dans notre sous-espace. L'occupation orbitale de cet état donnera une énergie inférieure ou égale à
l'énergie de l'occupation obtenue depuis l'espace récupéré. Donc cette occupation est une meilleure estimation de notre
occupation de l'état fondamental. On peut répéter le processus de récupération de configuration en utilisant cette nouvelle occupation et on peut itérer
jusqu'à ce que nos critères de convergence soient atteints. La diagonalisation quantique basée sur l'échantillonnage est rapide comparée à
d'autres algorithmes à court terme comme VQE. Elle est plus scalable et elle est robuste au bruit et aux erreurs d'échantillonnage. Elle nécessite quand même
qu'on prépare un bon ansatz avec une grande projection sous le support du vrai état fondamental de notre système. Si rien du tout n'est connu
sur notre vrai état fondamental, SQD devra peut-être être utilisé conjointement avec d'autres méthodes pour d'abord en apprendre plus sur l'état fondamental
et l'approcher itérativement.
SQD joue un rôle critique dans la suite émergente d'algorithmes hybrides classiques-quantiques et est l'un des
plus grands moteurs vers l'informatique quantique utile.